Kerry Kane bear may have been deadly for
its characters but the cast reporter Lee
had a blast making the film here's what
their drugged up Predator co-star looked
like in real life Beth we should go
[Applause]
[Music]
make no mistake while cocaine Bears a
few big name talents in its curse the
bear is a real star of the show of
course no amount of wrangling could
allow the production team to use a real
bear for all of the wild sequences in
the movie so how did they get the right
version on screen as it turns out the
drug-addle the creature was actually
played by a motion capture performer
with a surprisingly impressive
background director Elizabeth Banks was
well aware of the rest of making a movie
with such a wild narrative still she was
set on developing cocaine bear with
serious themes and more substance and
just a bunch of over-the-top violence
that means that she went all out on the
production insisting they recruit
top-notch players including the actor
who would bring the bear to life luckily
the perfect person was available Alan
Henry a motion capture performer who
trained under among other talents Andy
Circus in the field of motion capture
circus pretty much changed the game
through his work on films like the Lord
of the Rings trilogy and the Planet of
the Apes franchise Alan Henry Sports
some mean credits himself too he's done
most capture for some of the best
superhero movies of all time such as
Avengers end game outside of superhero
franchises he has a slew of appearances
and other franchises like The Hobbit and
The Hunger Games according to Banks
getting a talent of Henry's caliber for
the motion capture was necessary for how
demanding the role was Banks told Jimmy
Fallon that Henry deserves credit for
all the work he did he walks as a
quadruped on all fours on these like
special like any
killer bear may have been tough for
Henry but the actor seem to enjoy his
time on the production he tweeted I had
such a blast working on this film
Elizabeth is a great director with
strong dramatic and comedic Instinct I
have to hand it to the VFX team they
added so much powdery glory to the work
I did on set while cocaine Bears a hell
of a movie shooting the film was a
surreal of an experience as one might
expect especially when it came time for
the actors to shoot alongside Henry in
talking about Henry emotion capture
performers in general Kerry Russell told
The Daily Beast these guys are amazing
but also it is a grown man in a unitard
acting like a bear in front of you
despite the weirdness of filming it
still gave Henry a chance to bond with
his fellow castmates and crew members
when he wasn't pretending to be a bear
on hard drugs cast member O'Shea Jackson
Jr told Digital Spy that the team took
to calling the bear Allen meanwhile
Alder and Aaron Reich said Henry got his
very own trailer on the set of the
production which simply featured the
identifying term bear on its exterior
knowing that Henry was acting as a bear
in the original footage for cocaine bear
is the sort of thing that might stick in
the mind of viewers on their next watch
as Elizabeth Banks put it in an
interview with variety you don't see a
single frame of him in the movie but I
feel his spirit in all of the shots of
cocaine bear
foreign